Hey, come on, get your stuff.
Let's go get.
you're showing off.
Maybe a little.
I have always really loved Marvel movies.
Madame Web was very imposing to me.
Cassie,
where this movie is before she ends up in a wheelchair.
She's hyper intelligent
and her greatest superpower is her mind.
I knew he was going to die.
I saw it featured
when Cassie begins to experience her clairvoyance.
She thinks she's losing her mind.
You are the only one who can change the future.
Madame Web is unlike any other superhero.
When you think about how Spider-Man flies
through the air or Venom,
when he changes, it's
so mythical to us that with her it's all psychological.
I can see the future,
and I found that incredibly exciting to explore
strongly that
these visions are quite fragmented
because she doesn't see anything clearly.
I've seen that man before.
So who is he kill since he was in the Amazon
with my mom right before she died.
Madame Web brings
these four superheroes worlds together.
You don't think this is weird how we're all connected?
It's honestly, like,
the least weird thing that's happened all day.
It's the genesis
and the inception of what will become air.
Showing us maybe a little.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel and Sony dropped
the new Madame Web trailer.
So we finally got a look at what's actually going on.
So it budget Easter eggs
here, a bunch of Spider-Man stuff, too.
So we'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
But the whole idea is that you see Dakota Johnson's
Cassandra Web sort of in the process
of getting her powers, like you see her in the future
when she already has her powers of precedence,
but she hasn't been able to completely control
space and time yet,
like in the featurette, she says that it's before
she winds up in the wheelchair.
Most people remember that version of Madame Web.
If you don't remember Spider-Man, the animated series,
I would definitely recommend checking it out.
It is one of the best Spider-Man series of all time.
But Madame Web was huge during that series,
like the full version of Madame Web in the chair.
That version was actually played
by Stanley's wife, Joan in real life.
there was even a joke about it
in one of the final episodes where Spider-Man
actually travels to a universe
where he meets Stan Lee at the Marvel offices.
It was a super meta episode.
that's
basically
Stan Lee saying that his wife sounds really nice.
But the way they start the trailer off.
She's actually at the four star diner,
which is a location from the Spider-Man comics.
they're facing off a version of Ezekiel Simms,
who has his own Spider-Man powers, who's coming to kill
all these different versions of characters
who become Spider Woman because of who they become.
But when he's attacking them here in this diner,
they haven't become Spider-Woman yet.
Sydney Sweeney is playing Julia Carpenter.
You see her in her costume later in the trailer.
It looks like her costume in the comics.
this is Anya Corazon.
This is her in her costume later in the trailer.
And this is Mattie Franklin.
And this is her in her costume.
Later in the trailer, but later in the timeline.
Obviously.
the whole idea is they have this sort of Terminator
like time travel plot Rehab, Dakota Johnson's
Madame Web character, trying to save them
from being killed in the past by Ezekiel Sims.
end, even though you only briefly see,
like the back of her head,
like she's not a big character in these trailers.
So problematic, like the next trailer
Emma Roberts is supposed to be playing Mary Parker.
Peter Parker's biological mother, and Adam
Scott
is supposed to be playing a young version of Uncle Ben.
They're supposed to be big parts of the story.
So I think part of the idea is that Ezekiel
Simms is going around in the past, Terminator style,
trying to kill all these versions
of both Spider-Man and Spider Woman.
the most part, this trailer
just wants to focus on Madame Web, slowly
getting her powers.
then throughout the trailer, you see her slowly
gaining the ability to actually control those powers,
like control space and time.
For those of you wondering,
this is taking place in the Venom universe, primarily,
obviously connected to Spider-Man and Marvel Universe
to tangentially,
because they're connected those during Spider-Man,
No Way home.
just starting at the beginning of the trailer, though,
she sees the four star diner,
like I said, location from the Spider-Man comics.
this seems like after
she's already learned to control her powers
a little bit, but before the other versions of Spider
Woman have gotten close
to becoming versions of Spider Woman like,
they barely have any idea of what's going on.
like, they're all versions of Sarah
Connor who have no idea what's going on
until you get to the events of Terminator two.
which seem like it happened
at some point later in the movie.
look that not waiting to the sequel before
Sarah Connor, so to speak like these versions
of Sarah Connor become badasses.
This is Matty Franklin. This is Anya Corazon.
This is Julia Carpenter.
And I think Mary Parker
might actually be working at this diner.
Then we see Ezekiel Simms walking in.
In his full Spider-Man suit.
Relatively speaking.
He's actually a bit of a newer Spider-Man villain.
He debuted in 2001 in Amazing Spider-Man
volume two, Number 30.
he got his powers from the spider totem.
He's connected to Moreland.
A lot of people wondered if that character
would actually be involved in the Spider-Verse movies.
Do Just because they're all connected
to the spider society, so to speak.
They already connected Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse to like the live action spider
movies like Donald Glover's Prowler is the live action
one from Spider-Man homecoming in.
It basically sounds like the idea
is that all these versions of Spider Woman Spider-Man
eventually team up to stop him in the future,
and he's trying to come back into the past
to stop them before that happens.
basically,
all of his powers are like Spider-Man's basic powers,
like I said, but he got them from the spider totems.
He wasn't bitten by a radioactive spider
or anything like that.
then basically you see her lose and she controlling
time, says, Let's try this again
and literally tries it again by going back in time.
so it is interesting to see
how they're pulling off her time traveling ability.
We see the New York City landscape.
She's working as an EMT
because she's trying to save people,
using her abilities, basically they show her
venom verse version of her origin story,
basically like a near-death experience
and starts to unlock her abilities.
we see Adam Scott, who's working as an EMT with her,
who is supposed to be the younger version
of Uncle Ben during the movie part of the idea, I think
is also going to tease the birth of Peter Parker.
Spider-Man in maybe at some point insecure.
Simmons will also try to kill Mary Parker
so that doesn't wind up happening.
She starts to see the future.
She sees a version of Ezekiel Simms coming to
the subway car walking around on a New York City train.
Should just be sus enough, like,
Wait a minute, you're not wearing shoes.
That's the dirtiest thing I've ever seen.
Something is weird about you.
She starts having visions of him
killing all these different versions of Spider Woman
across the train They haven't fully explained
why all the different women
wind up on the same train because they didn't
get their powers in the exact same incident.
Like, it all didn't happen at the same time.
They don't really give a release date in the trailer.
They just say that it's being released
at some point next year.
Sounds like it's going to be relatively
early next year.
part of the idea, though.
I think some of the movie is supposed to take place
about 20 years ago inside New York City.
Like, the technology just makes it seem like
it's 20 years ago gist of the timeline works out
with Peter Parker being an adult in present day,
there might be a version of Jay
Jonah Jameson in the movie
because Matty Franklin is related to him biologically,
and he was obviously operating at this point 20 years
before Peter Parker was born.
if we're talking about Ezekiel Simms
getting his powers from the spider totem,
unless they've changed that for the movie,
on your corazon is one of the other characters
who gets her powers from the Spider Society,
who granted her abilities using a ritual.
but they might just simplify
that for the purposes of the movie
and it looks like they're saying the Cassandra web,
like Madame Web got her powers biologically
like she says her mother was researching spiders
before she was born Notice he's got the red umbrella
that's just meant to be a Spider-Man
Easter egg like red for Spider-Man's costume.
they kind of did something similar
in the Kraven trailer.
But like you see him in the woods with spiders
all around him.
the only difference in this trailer is that you see
a bunch of people in Spider-Man related costumes
For the most part, the women's costumes are accurate
to their comic book costumes, though,
You see Sydney Sweeney
using a version of her Sonic webbing from the comics.
So this is comic book accurate to her abilities,
what I'm guessing, though, just the way
they're building the hype in the trailer here is that
by the end of the movie, you'll see versions of them
using their powers in a big final battle against him
then there's the obvious time travel trope.
Then in her having to save them,
their futures have already been changed
a little bit, look in the original versions
of their timelines where they all became spider-woman.
She didn't interact with them in this way.
so the fact they're having this version
of the first Terminator movie where she has
to save them Kyle Reese style,
she's already changing their origins stories.
so in this new timeline that they create,
they'll have to explain how they get their powers
in a slightly different way.
notice the giant red glowing P very obvious metaphor
for Peter Parker.
notice in the logo too. It's red for Spider-Man.
Also has the webbing all over it and the outline
of the Statue of Liberty in New York City
basically one of the other big questions
when they announced the movie two is she
she's going to be part of the reason
why all these different versions of characters
from like, say, like the Spider-Man universe connect
with the venom verse, pulling everyone together
by the events of Secret Wars,
because they actually kind of did a version
of this during Spider-Man, the animated series
where she brought Spider-Man to battle World.
part of the idea, I think Sony is trying to build up
to their own version of Avengers
Infinity War in Avengers, Endgame,
separately from Secret Wars, and like all the other
big Multiverse crossover stuff with MCU, Spider-Man
So I do think in success,
like if everything goes well with this movie
and you know, who knows big question mark there
they'll use her abilities as a way to explain
how everybody starts coming together.
Like she'll be the version of Doctor Strange
that sort of goes around the multiverse,
collecting everyone,
putting this multiverse team of Spider-Man together.
There are a bunch of announcements too, in the MCU
side of things about Marvel changing Avengers,
Kang Dynasty, Avengers six Secret Wars
because they're moving away from the Kang plot.
I'll try to do a video about that
at some point in the next couple of days
because that would actually be a pretty big deal.
Like them pivoting away from Kang towards Dr. Doom.
if there's any big Easter eggs
or references that you spotted in the trailers
that I didn't talk about in this video,
just write them below in the comments and I'll do more
videos about Madame Web as soon as we get more footage
with more of the characters,
like more Mary Parker,
more Peter Parker, Spider-Man, Easter Eggs, Hopefully,
because this movie is set like 20 years ago,
we won't see Uncle Ben having to die again.
But because it is a Terminator style plot
and she gets to replay events over and over.
We'll probably see the characters die
a couple of different ways.
Speaking of Sony live action crossover,
I do think that we'll see more of that
during Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse.
I think the idea that they were sort
of dipping their toe in that water like live action
animation crossover during Spider-Man
across the spider-verse so beyond the Spider-Verse
will end with like a much bigger version of that,
hopefully to prepare some of the characters
like Miles Morales for live action
crossover in secret Wars.
my. Early theory is that the Post-Credits scene
will involve some sort of live action venom crossover,
kind of like we saw in the Morbius movie
with the big Sinister Six teaser at their post-credits
scene, probably a couple of Big Spider-Man references
to in that post-credits scene.
But everyone click here for my full Loki Season
two Episode six Finale video
and click here for my Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse Teaser Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!